morning day 1 of quarantine yesterday
was a very long day we spent more than
30 hours I would say almost 40 hours on
the road traveling from Wuhan to the
world so everybody basically just
checked in last night got a few
amenities like shower gel etc and went
straight to bed everyone was so tired so
this is the accommodation we have here
room and a bath Oh God
can't wait for one of those we've been
told that if we go into any communal
area we have to keep our masks on at all
times
however we are allowed to take them off
in our rooms about to have breakfast
breakfast has arrived
we've got a nice selection of bacon
sausages you know the information we're
being given at the moment is that we
should try to stay as isolated as
possible but we are free to move around
and we can talk to each other but if we
can stay isolated in as much as we can
then they would prefer that but you know
everyone's been sensible here everyone's
taking the necessary precautions using
hand sanitizers when they go out and
come back in okay this is where we are
allowed to come outside as you can see
just over there they have put a fence
around the perimeter to stop us from
getting out everybody here all eighty
three of us are in good health at the
moment nobody's complaining of any
symptoms of the virus everybody's in
good spirits albeit subdued this is the
kitchen we've got microwave oven it's
quite a surreal situation obviously it's
something that you would never expect to
experience in in life
we've been welcomed with open arms here
the staff have been fantastic and if
quite everybody at ease with everything
that they've done for us and you know
really we can't thank them enough for
everything that they're doing and
everything that they've done so far I
know it's only been a few hours we've
been here you know less than a day but
honestly it feels like we've been here
for a very long time